you know what
let's do this
[Applause]
and this
if that moment between dua lipa and
megan the stallion from the grammy
awards seems familiar it might just be
because whitney houston and mariah carey
did it first just get ready
it all went down on sunday night when
the ladies hit the stage to present the
best new artist award wearing matching
versace
not just all my look
well i was told i had the exclusive the
pair stunned rocking the same black
dress and shiny leggings accessorizing
with oversized safety pins and chunky
jewelry i'm gonna have to have a talk
with donatella
donatella of course being designer
donatella versace who joined them to fix
the fashion faux pas
okay
let me fix this
you know what
let's do this
and this
now these are my girls
thank you donatella
now we both look like winners
well fans were quick to point out that
the matchy-matchy moment was seemingly a
tribute to this memorable bit from the
1998 mtv video music awards
that's a one of a kind huh
it looks kind of familiar that that's
what they told me yeah they told me mine
was too but you know what what baby
fortunately i come prepared for
situations like this try it on me
[Applause]
all right all right
because uh
i could do it better
yeah mariah and whitney may have entered
the stage wearing the same dress
you look good now all right now that's a
page turner no you look good but the
fantasy singer left with a mini lbd
while the bodyguard star looked fire in
a high-low look a lot of body body audio
so what did mariah think of it she loved
it tweeting try it on me along with a
sweet message to the late whitney love
you and miss you queen
i'm so excited dua and megan's grammy's
performance comes less than a month
after they released their track sweetest
pie
[Music]
and earlier in the night the british
singer stunned in this versace leather
bondage number from the fall winter 1992
miss s m collection and if it looks
familiar too it's because cindy crawford
rocked it back in 1992 to the mtv vmas
dua also debuted a new blonde do while
meg looked stunning in this animal print
roberto cavalli dress
i did what i had to do
of course this has already been a big
year for the rapper who recently
graduated from college e.t chatted with
meg back in february about her upcoming
performance at coachella
you know i like to surprise the hotties
i'll never like to tell them too much
i've definitely been like a little
absent on social media because i've been
getting my mind right i've been working
on my music so this year when i finally
do pop back out it's gonna be like
she was really working
as for dua this time last year she took
home the grammy for pop vocal album you
know to be alongside so many of my peers
so many artists that inspire me was just
mind-blowing now she's busy on tour and
launching a fashion collection with puma
so needless to say these lady bosses are
crushing it same dress or
[Music]
not you